these are so much more than gadgets
they're designed classics
coveted and imitated in their millions
the historical artifacts milestones in
the unstoppable growth of one
corporation and their expressions of a
philosophy which is profoundly shaped
our relationship with tech you know it's
true when something exceeds your ability
to understand how it works it sort of
becomes magical that's apples head
designer said Johnny I've who was 19
2012 now he's leaving Apple to start his
own consultancy after 20 years defining
how tech feels and functions he had here
to minimalism so he wanted things to be
as simple as possible it's clear and
clean as possible and just to work
supremely well so a good example is the
first iPod all it was was a hard drive
it was a white box when he put a simple
dial on the front of it he turned a hard
drive into a music machine so Johnny
moved to Apple in 1992 but it wasn't
until Steve Jobs returned that he really
got into his stride from the iMac to the
iPod to the big one Apple is going to
reinvent the phone after Jobs is death
so Johnny carried on with the successor
Tim Cook although some wondered if his
heart was still in it seemed as if
Johnny Ives enthusiasm has waned a
little bit over the last few years I've
been covering Apple for a long time and
it used to be the case that you would
see him very prominently at the Apple
events in in California it would be
pre-recorded video with him expounding
how wonderful the new product is and
there have been less and less of these
recently and it seems to be from an
outsider's point of view just him
stepping away ever so slightly
surely I've might be getting out at just
the right time because Apple is moving
away from products and towards services
his unique skills and no longer in such
demand but his legacy will remain tech
that's desirable Steve Jobs once called
computers bicycles for the mind so
Johnny I've gave that idea form now it's
up to the rest of us to keep those
machines under control rollin man thawb
Sky News